I think after tonight
you see the Lord has vindicated us,
right?
Ma Rumble, make Rumble great again. Read
the Gospels. Kathle Ryan Maker. You see
the Lord has vindicated us. When I say
us, because you are my family, you have
stood with me. You have prayed for me.
You've supported me financially. You
didn't condemn me. You loved me. And you
knew I'm a sinner. I'm not a saint. and
I've never thought I'm better than you
ever. And you've prayed for me and in
Jesus name.
Glory to the father to son lord Jesus
Christ and holy spirit. You have
supported me and continue to support me
because I couldn't do the work without
you. So if I have been vindicated in
your eyes, I don't care what others
think. People are going to hate me. If
you go to their live stream, people were
reporting back to me and sending me
clips. If you go to their live stream,
you see
that their fanboys, their cult followers
do not care about Jesus Christ our Lord,
right?
Jesus Christ our Lord. They're fanboys.
They don't care about the Bible. They
don't care about scripture. They don't
fear the Lord Jesus Christ. It's about
their idols. May God destroy every form
of idolatry, blasphemy from us. But
those who don't
idolize David or me but love Jesus
Christ, they saw that everything I said
was 100% spoton.
100% spot on.
I was confirmed and vindicated by the
Lord Jesus Christ. You see? So, I need
you to focus. The Lord Jesus confirmed
everything I've said and vindicated me,
right? and I'm going to give Jesus
Christ all the glory and honor. They
can't say anything bad about me. I have
receipts. I have the documents. Even the
court document that they try to use
against me only will backfire against
them. But God exposed them one by one.
But I don't want to rejoice over it.
Even Tadius, whom I call Tattius Da, one
of David Wood's leading cult followers
who likes to play David Wood's clips
because David Wood platforms him,
manifested
and embarrassed himself on my liveream.
Not on my liveream, on my comment
section. And yet he thought he was being
vindicated. And let me show you how God
humiliated him further. I know you're
watching, Tadius.
I want you to see how God now exposed
you. Okay, watch her. Let's go through
the documentation one at a time. Watch
him accusing me of being the Muhammad
hijab. And what's ironic, every slur I
use against them, they use against me.
How original, how genius. I call David
with the Muhammad hijab of Christian
apologetics. He calls me that. See,
nothing original with them. They can't
help but laugh at my sense of humor. And
they can't help but laugh at me cussing
people. They love it. You see it. You
guys are watching. I wasn't watching.
You're telling me they were laughing
hard because they love it deep down
inside. They love it. But they don't
know how to discredit me except that I
have bipolar. All right. So, I do. Okay.
I have bipolar. And so what?
And okay, I got bipolar.
And
so what?
Okay, I'm a narcissist. May Jesus save
me. Okay.
All right. Um,
I got Asberers and
autism and
OCD and All right. So what?
Okay.
All right.
And
what does that mean? I don't know what
it means.
Now watch how God exposes them. Watch
here. Remember Tadius wants to call me
out to repent for the my language.
Here's Tattius.
>> Big Brother house. This is Deina. You're
live on channel 4. Please do not swear.
>> What reason exactly? Because I'm afraid
of Christian history. Give me a break,
you [__] clown. Give me a
break.
[__]
>> What was that about cussing? Wow.
What was that, Tus about me cussing
people out? My language. I need to
repent. Okay.
Now, here is where I stand vindicated.
And I'm going to go through scripture
again. Here it is. This is was sent to
me today guys. I promise you the Lord is
my witness. I didn't watch. People were
watching sent me this. Here you go.
>> I didn't hide them. I thought there is
no need to hide them and I can't bother
hiding them. Uh when I walked around for
example with a woman uh who was who was
seen with me on a uh on a on video
footage that was quite out there in your
face.
>> Okay.
>> I made no efforts to hide that for those
who are who are wondering.
>> No, it's not. You made no efforts. You
got caught. God exposed you, humiliated
you. Come clean, brother. Stop
justifying your adultery. Watch.
>> Uh I'm also going to be very open and
honest about it since we are here and
talking about it. It is actually uh
somebody that I've recently met and that
I have recently come to grow very fond
of and feel a lot of love for. And
>> I feel a lot He's in love with a woman.
He's not divorced. He just left his
wife. In the eyes of God, he's not even
validly divorced. He just admit to you
he's in love with another woman.
Meaning, he met her in Israel, went with
her Israel. This is now a blatant
confession of adultery. What do you guys
not see?
What do you guys not see?
He just destro I I I swore I thought
they're going to come with receipts.
They're going to expose me. And I'm
like, what could they Honestly, I was
thinking, God is my witness. What? Lord,
what can they say about me? I got all
the receipts and the emails.
How are they going to expose me? They
got something that I don't know. I swear
I was like, maybe there's something new
because I've been brutally honest with
you. In fact, brethren, I can say this
without trying to be arrogant. I don't
think you've met a more honest apologist
than me,
and I'm not trying to boast.
And it turned out they destroyed their
reputation. Do you guys know that,
right? Those who don't worship and
idolize David, apostate prophet, even
those who hate me, they will now be
disgusted with both David Wood and
Apostate Prophet. It's over for them
because you know what AP just did? He
just confirmed David Wood was friends.
David Woods, right, was friends
with a guy that he knew had left his
wife and had already started an
adulterous relationship with another
woman and he's platforming him.
Shadow and watch it. Can someone clip
that same Fina? Someone clip me clip
where he said
where he said that he ignored the advice
of his spiritual father. That even his
spiritual father said this is not right.
That's a lie. My brother, his wife said
he abandoned her. I'll give you the
receipt. He left her. That's a lie. And
even leaving her doesn't mean he has the
right to be in another relationship.
Separation is not divorce. Let's hear it
again.
He admits he's in love with a woman
who's not his wife while he's still
married in the eyes of God.
>> I didn't hide them. I thought there is
no need to hide them and I can't bother
hiding them. Uh when I walked around,
for example, with a woman uh who was was
seen with me on a uh on a on video
footage that was quite out there in your
face.
I made no efforts to hide that. For
those who are uh who are wondering, uh
I'm also going to be very open and
honest about it since we are here and
talking about it. It is actually uh
somebody that I've recently met and that
I have recently come to grow very fond
of and feel a lot of love for and um
talk to.
That's it. Because
I am no longer in a committed
relationship.
>> Who cares? Who gives a damn?
No one gives a damn whether you think
because you're not in committed
relationship that God doesn't think
you're still bound to her. You're not
God. You're not a prophet and apostle.
You're not the standard. I'm going to
show you scripture. That's why I
challenged him. Remember he deleted his
post. Bring me on so I can ask you the
right biblical questions. Why did he
ever accept me on that challenge?
Why didn't he ever bring me on?
But I'm the one in hinge, right? You can
see how unhinged I am.
>> Because we have agreed, all those
involved have agreed that we are
separated.
>> Okay, I want to show you what his wife
said. We all agreed, right? So his wife
agreed he can now go and commit adultery
when she is a devout Eastern Orthodox.
Really? So he's saying his wife also is
willfully sinning against God, complicit
in his adultery. Okay. I mean, I don't
know.
He admits he's in love with another
woman. Guys, he admits you don't fall in
love in a week. This means it's been a
while, which means he wanted to find a
reason to bail out. Now, I understand
why his wife was quick to accept the
invitation of Iggy because
she already saw what he was up to. If
you know women, women don't check out
unless you've done something.
So she must have seen right the writing
on the wall. But now watch
>> and moved on.
>> All those involved in this
in this entire thing that I've just
talked about. All those directly
involved in this
>> are aware of every single thing that I
have said, acknowledge every single
thing that I've said and are okay with
every single thing that I've said.
>> They're okay.
>> Nobody has been wronged.
>> Wait, hold on.
If you did say your spiritual father
didn't approve of this, how's everyone
okay with this? And if your wife, not
your ex-wife, she's not your ex-wife
yet, said you left her,
how is she okay with it? Is this guy
delusional?
>> Nobody has been treated with injustice.
>> No one has been treated injustice.
>> But if you listen to people like Sam
Shimon, it might
>> Okay, it might sound okay. Now here, now
she deleted her Twitter account when she
said yes to Iggy, but I can see why. But
guess what? I had sent him on the phone
the message before she deleted it. Does
that sound like it's mutual?
Good afternoon. Stop asking me about
Revan. He left me. It's over.
Does that sound like this was mutual
right there? See, facts don't lie. See,
facts are a stubborn thing, right? They
can bring up my family. They have
nothing to say. Let me put it straight
to the point.
It is a lie from the pit of hell that I
abandoned my daughters. It is a lie from
the pit of hell
that I
neglected them and avoided paying for
them. Here, I'm going to now give you
receipts.
By the grace of Jesus Christ, let me let
something out in the back. The Lord
because of you guys blessing the
ministry,
I had saved money
so that I could deposit it in the bank
account of my daughters so that they
would be taken care of for several
years. Why?
so that in case my ministry support
drops and I don't have money, at least I
saved up for them so that they'll be
okay until I get back on my feet. Okay?
Because you got to pay child support. My
ex-wife will confirm, my daughters will
confirm because they saw it. They had
been taken care of so that in case
because remember I'm in full-time
ministry, brother. My support can drop
and then I got to do something else. So
I always worry about them. Let me tell
you what if my support drops. I don't
want to affect them. Glory to the triune
God. And I want to praise God for you
guys. You guys in my toughest times have
supported me because I depend on
support. I saved up by the grace of God.
So that at least
for the next three years, they don't
have to worry. It's in their bank
account. So, if I do lose support,
then at least they won't hurt because I
can try to do what I can to get back on
my feet.
So, when they tell you he was hiding
money from his daughters, see, they're
sons of Satan,
right? Sons of Satan.
Why? I wasn't hiding from my daughters.
I was hiding the money from my ex-wife's
lawyers so that I could deposit it in
the account for them. and my ex-wife and
my children were there when I deposited
into their account.
And if you want proof that even beyond
that, here text message from my ex-wife
who just manifested because I exposed
her again. I want you to see that.
What is she asking me
here? Proof. See, I bring receipts.
Let me show you. She's watching now.
She's manifesting.
Watch me.
Watch me. Let's go.
Here you go.
Let me see. She just asked me to send
$900 for my daughter.
Okay, she just said, "Yeah, can you send
$900 for be?" Oh, right here. Here you
go. Here you go. Proof. Watch. Watch
here, guys.
Please send me a little money for Sia.
She has two sessions.
I want to buy three more $900.
Okay.
Not bad for a guy who's abandoning his
kids. And I said, "All right, well, I'm
in the state. You know, the only way I
can do it is if I send it to you Apple
Pay, but my Apple Pay is not working
here." And then I told her, "Have my
kids here. I want you to hear this.
You're going to be my witnesses."
Okay? I want you to hear this, right?
And look what she says about David Wood.
Look,
>> does she need the 900? What does she
need?
Okay. right here.
>> Okay,
>> I just checked my Chase. I only have
822.
I usually deposit money in it, but I'm
not in the state. So, if I send you
money, I can't because I have to be in
the state to put money in the account.
So, God, I don't get there to the 17th.
But then, if you want me to then PayPal
the 900 today, that I can do. You got to
let me know. Watch
>> and have the girls pray for the support.
I don't lose support because if I lose
support then I'm going to have to do
something else because yeah they're
going to do the show today. Sam Shabot
exposed someone's going to cry so they
have surprise for me and I'm shaking in
my boots. So, uh, if I lose support,
then I just got to find something else
to do to make sure I don't dip in the
money for the girls that I've saved cuz
I got to save money for these girls so I
can give them something and die
at peace with Christ and I leave them
money.
>> Well, let me know how you want me to
send you money. Have them pray God
protect that people will not stop
supporting because of the lies they're
going to spread about me. But hey, it's
life. That's life.
>> See, you see, I'm shaking right now.
Look at her response.
Look at the response.
Remember, they'll quote my ex-wife
against me, right? Look what she says
about David Wood.
Why is David doing this? Do you know men
can have a Jezebel spirit, too? The fact
that he wants to see you destroyed kind
of proves that. No. Damn, David. Oh, so
you'll take my word, my ex-wife's words
when she bashes me. That's gospel truth.
But when she says, "You have a Jezebel
spirit," meaning you're Satan and you're
envious, you want to destroy me. No, she
doesn't know what she's talking about.
And that was today.
So, what was that about me abandoning my
children?
One more time, guys.
What's up, home? But wait, David, what?
You're going by her testimony against me
and you know the facts because of the
emails. Is she lying?
Hold on.
Because you believe her when she
demonizes me, right?
Man,
I don't know, man. They say Jezebels
recognize other Jezebels. Right.
Right. They say Jezebels recognize other
Jezebels. Narcissists recognize other
narcissists. Sociopaths recognize other
sociopaths. Right. Mr. Reynolds.
And by the way, I can't show him on
camera. Mr. Reynolds is sitting here.
I've told you that God put people in my
life who've been there and saw
everything. When I got thrown out of my
house, this is the man, Mr. Reynolds,
right here. He doesn't talk about it. He
was there November 2017. He had
converted the garage into an apartment.
Mr. Reynolds, God bless you. I know you
don't like to talk about it. Did you let
me stay in that apartment garage free of
charge?
>> Yes.
>> Say louder.
>> Why is he still with me in Florida if
I'm the white beater, Mr. Reynolds? But
you're with the notorious white beater,
Mr. Not Reynolds.
>> Yep. Yep.
>> Oh, you mean so the people who've been
there in my life, who've been there and
see what I went through, they still love
me and they're with me. He's right here.
Even though he's not the most handsomest
thing to look at at night, he's right
here. And guess what? Mr. Reynolds paid
for the hotel room.
And even took me to Trader Joe to get me
to lose these love handles so I can look
good for Patrick or David. Even though
when he break he he readjusted my spine.
So I don't need to see a chiropractor,
Mr. Ellis. It's right there, man. So let
me let me finish it.
>> No, it's okay. So you see
Okay.
How come I give you facts,
documentation,
receipts?
Because I told you I don't fear these
guys and I try to be as honest with you
guys as possible, as much as I can.
That's it.